нагадаю що Міністерство освіти і науки
розробляє концепцію безпечної закладу
освіти Ми вже про це якось говорили з
паном міністром в нашому ефірі і зараз
хотілося б зрозуміти практичне втілення
цього і з цього я і почну розмову з
Сергієм шкарлетом міністром освіти і
науки України пане Сергію Вітаю
Доброго дня Слава Україні Героям слава
пана міністра ми вже з вами починали цю
розмову в ефірі і концепція безпечного
закладу освіти вона складається з двох
частин є методологічна яка в принципі не
вимагає надзвичайних фінансових зусиль
але є практичні рекомендації Якраз для
закладів освіти як їм бути безпечними
для наших е-е дітей і для дорослих теж і
Тут виникає питання фінансування
оскільки хтось мусить профінансувати
створення цього безпечного середовища чи
є відповідь на запитання де брати гроші
місцевим органам влади для таких
безпечних закладів освіти
за все за постійну увагу до проблем
освіти адже ми завжди говоримо про
освіту Ми усвідомлюємо що це про
майбутнє дійсно концепція безпечного
закладу так само і було підтверджено на
освітянському форумі з безпеки і
проходив на два тижні тому де було
присутня більше ніж 400 освітянських
регіонів України і наочно говорили саме
про дві складові цієї концепції
організаційна методична перша складова І
інфраструктурна от саме більше проблем
сьогодні є По інфраструктурні оскільки
вона вимагає кошти хочу сьогодні сказати
що концепція взагалі будується на певній
між
міжгалузевій співпраці Міністерство
освіти і науки Міністерства внутрішніх
справ державної служби надзвичайних
ситуацій
нацполіції місцевих органів і саме в
20х23 рік закладена цілювально вас
субвенція яка буде використовуватись
виключно на формування безпекових
гривень саме на на ці видатки і я чітко
розумію що сьогодні ми визначили це
випередження опорних шкіл в яких
навчаються більше ніж 250 дітей в яких
ще немає укриття які мають бути
організовані як укриття за за рахунок
цієї суббиці окрім того ми не стоїмо на
місці Ми дуже чітко Працюємо з нашими
закордонними донорами наприклад
Європейська комісія виділила Україні
саме в галузі освіти більше ніж 100
мільйонів євро на
формування саме укриттів школах і під цю
концепцію попадає
74 школи України так само опорні які
будуть облаштовані укриттям окрім того
ми працюємо з багатьма різними дрібними
[музика]
донорами
зокрема Східна Європа запустити програму
безпечна школа в нас 20 закладів освіти
будуть побудовані укриття Вінницька
Хмельницька Одеська область та міста
Київ Ми сьогодні чітко розуміємо що
юнісеф нам дав можливості облаштувати
більше ніж тисячу шкіл обладнанням для
укриття цей Карі мати аптечки ціла низка
ціла низка необхідних товарів
необхідних необхідної продукції яка б
забезпечувала саме безпечне перебування
дітей під час повітряної дороги в
укриття
покриття має бути в кожному закладі і
адже це відповідає концепції що заклад
освіти є територію у вас є державна
субвенція того Гаразд це вже пів справи
зроблено Тепер залишилося втілити на
практиці школам конкретним але наші
державні розрахунки бюджетні в тому
числі виходять з тривалості війни
впродовж 23-го року і це тепер ставить
руба питання про ЗНО цього року воно
було Зі зрозумілих причин скасоване А що
Міністерство планує наступного року
робити з цією тестовою системою для
випускників
Я вам дуже дякую за запитання як завжди
дуже актуальне дуже слушне трошки тільки
трошки уточнення в нісу оскільки ЗНО не
було скасоване воно певним чином
модернізувати саме на прийом 22-го року
Верховна Рада прийняла відповідний закон
за яким проводився замість ЗНО
національний мультиплективний тест
але це було лише на 22-й рік
Міністерство освіти і науки ще в вересні
місяці невиконання закону про загальну
середню освіту про освіту і про вищу
освіту вже запровадило наказ згідно з
яким ми мусимо запровадити в 23-му році
вступ за традиційним зовнішнім
незалежним оцінюванням при цьому
розраховуючи ви правильно абсолютно
сказали вірно сказали що ми бачимо що
23-й рік війна триває і ми мусимо мати
певну альтернативу під час активних
бойових дій щодо вступу і не можемо
зірвати вступну кампа тобто ЗНО є і
залишається в пріоритеті і сьогодні ЗНО
є єдиним інструментом вступу на 23-й рік
причому Міністерство освіти і науки
підготувало певну альтернативу
розширений модернізований національний
мультиплектний тест на 23-й рік
відповідний законопроекту п'ятницю був
проголосований на засіданні уряду І ми
його спрямовуємо на Верховну Раду далі
справа за депутатами які будуть
визначати спочатку профільного комітеті
потім в залі Верховної Ради щодо
можливості
випускникам 23-го року мати альтернативу
розширений національно мультиплідний
тест при вступі на е-е в на на
20.2023-24 навчальний рік і чи правильно
Я розумію що він передбачає якраз
можливість скласти цей національний
мультипредметний тест для тих
випускників які закінчуватимуть свою
освіту за кордоном вимушено
абсолютно вірно ми не обмежу
в межах України
приклад 2022 показав що більше ніж 30
тисяч випускників
2022 року змогли здати у 52 містах або
32-х країнах світу
національний мультипрем'єрний тест в
університетах або інший підготовлених
установах і змогли вступити на навчання
саме в українській університеті е
традиційний формат зовнішнього
незалежного оцінювання такої можливості
не передбачав а саме національний
мультипрем'єктний тест дав можливість
нам задіяти випускників які тимчасове
перебувають за кордоном для того щоб
вони вступили до навчання на закладів
вищої освіти така сама процедура
передбачається і на цей рік як
альтернатива ще раз нагадаю ЗНО є
безперечним інструментом вступу але
Міністерство освіти передбачило
можливість в разі
активних бойових дій продовження режиму
воєнного стану для того щоб випускники
мали альтернативу вступу по розширеному
національному
тиску пане Сергію у раз уже мова зайшла
про вступну кампанію до якої теж
звичайно треба готуватися заздалегідь
пригадую що цього року було
розширено пільги для вступників особливо
це стосувалося пільг для вступників з
тимчасово окупованих територій чи
прифронтових територій але президент
звертав увагу на те що варто також мати
певні пільги для дітей наших захисників
які воюють Скажіть будь ласка чи є вже
такі пільги і кого вони стосуються якщо
є
ви знаєте у нас безумовно Це і учасники
бойових дій особи з інвалідністю
внаслідок війни діти померлих учасників
революції гідності учасників бойових дій
або особи з
інвалідністю внаслідок війни діти один з
батьків яких загинув аби пропав безвісти
в районі проведення АТО діти з
інвалідністю та особи з інвалідністю
першої третьої групи особи які визнані
пострадах постраждалими учасниками
революції гідності тобто тут тут
ситуація якраз таки щодо пільги нашим
захисникам і їхнім дітям вона Ми дуже
ретельно це дотримуємось і дуже з
великою повагою ставимось до нашої
збройних сил або захисників і захисниць
Окрім цього я хочу нагадати що було
прийнято
дві постанови Кабінету Міністрів Які
стосувалися наприклад компенсації витрат
закладу вищої освіти у першому весняному
семестрі для тих хто втратив житло
Втратив роботу тимчасово втратив
можливість платити за навчання перший
семестр держава з резервного фонду
виділила 87 млн грн для покриття витрат
закладах вищої освіти декомпенсації
витрат закладу що освіти саме за тих
дітей які внаслідок війни опинились в
складних складних обставинах Окрім цього
була прийнята постанова жовтня місяця
прийняли постанову яка б теж давала
можливість перевести на на навчання за
рахунок коштів державного бюджету
студентів другого третього четвертого
курсу другого курсу магістратури які
опинилися в тих територіях які визначав
наказ мінреінтеграції тобто як особливо
небезпечних територій нагадаю що вступ
саме
вступ вступ наших студентів на перший
курс і перший курс магістратури
відбувався вже за переліком знов-таки
квоти два для тих особливо небезпечних
територій і в цьому році більше ніж 11
тисяч студентів в порівнянні з двома
тисячами Минулого року вступили з охотою
два тобто без зовнішнього незалежного
оцінювання за окремою процедурою вступу
виключно за онлайн або учнем з
учненської співбесіду і вступили на
навчання за кошти державного бюджету
хочу сьогодні проінформувати наші колег
і ректорів і батьків що вже перші 13
студенти окремим пакетом були направлені
документи щодо переводу їх на місця за
рахунок коштів державного бюджету з тих
особливо небезпечних територій на
виконання доручень президента України
щодо забезпечення соціального захисту
саме цих дітей студентів які навчаються
в закладах ви щось
Дякую пане міністр за цю інформацію вам
результативного і наскільки це можливо
зараз спокійного дня Сергій шкарлет
Міністр освіти і науки України був з
нами в ефірі